KEVIN BOUWMEESTER:
Welcome to the session
about how to create an API
that your developers love
and that your developers
actually want to use.
Maybe you are a
developer, and then
you probably know
what you like and you
know what you want to use.
So we are then just here
to confirm to that, I hope.
So my name is Kevin Bouwmeester.
I work at Google as
a customer engineer.
I'm part of the Apigee team,
so I joined Google in November
through the acquisition.
And I'll be taking you through
a short introduction, just a few
slides about APIs and why
we're using APIs these days
and what Apigee is
doing with APIs.
And after that, I'll
go for a demo, where
I'll show Apigee Edge,
our product, and how
we can use that to
actually obtain our goal
to create these nice
APIs that everybody
is so enthusiastic about.
After that, we'll
have [INAUDIBLE]
from ABN AMRO on stage, and ABN
AMRO is going through a journey
where they're
actually transforming
the bank into something
that's more digital, that
has APIs, of course.
It has a great developer
portal, and actually
a lot of new, innovative ideas
around payments and banking.
So with that being
said, let's get started.
I hope that by the end, by
the time we get to the end,
you have a pretty
good idea on what
an API should look like, and
hopefully, a lot of new ideas
which you could use
in your own programs.
So, but before we
get started to that,
let's just think about why APIs.
So just a question
to the audience.
Who of you are
working for a company
or are in a position today
where you offer APIs?
Wow.
That's great.
It's great.
For the guys in
the first row, it
was around 30%, 40%
of the audience.
So that's great.
And who is a developer?
Who is using APIs?
Wow, that's 50%, maybe.
Great.
Nice to know.
So this might be
preaching to the choir,
but I will just start
with a few slides.
I won't spend a lot of
time on this around APIs.
The guys who raised their
hand for the first question,
you probably are within
a digital business.
[CHEERING]
If they promise me at
the end of my talk,
it's more louder than that.
Digital businesses--
so digital businesses,
they have something
to do with APIs.
They are trying to offer
services and data through APIs.
And this data comes
from systems, right?
Backend systems, which could
be COBOL, [INAUDIBLE]----
I know banks have a
role of COBOL still.
But it could be
brand-new systems,
like something you build on
App Engine in Google Cloud,
or a Node.js app that
you're running on your Roku,
for example.
But the thing is, you want
these data and services to be
consumed by your customers,
by your partners which
you collaborate with,
and also internally
with an organization,
maybe for internal apps
or to your employees.
So if you zoom in
to how this works,
actually you come
down to this, which
is the digital value chain.
And this is just a
slight-- we think it's
really important, with Apigee.
This is what we use to
talk to our customers,
where we actually try to
investigate where you want
to go to, which of the digital
initiatives that organizations
want to achieve, all the way to
the other end, which backends
need to be used for that?
And there's a whole bunch
in the middle, which
is the developer, the guys
who raised the question
at the second question I asked.
And there's the API team,
of course, the team that's
trying to operate these
APIs, trying to secure it,
trying to get these
APIs available,
getting them out there.
And there's actually two aspects
to this digital value chain.
You have the left side, which
is more on consumption, where
you actually have your APIs.
They have to be used.
They have to be documented.
You have to get--
to find your developers, get
them in, get them onboarded.
And then they can start building
and build cool new solutions.
Then there's the
right part, which
is the more technical
part, where you actually
want to get data from
your backend systems
and want to make them
available, in a secure way,
in the right format, with
traffic management on there.
We want to get analytics on the
usage and everything like that.
So there are a lot of
things to think about.
So I will touch these
two aspects both,
but I will focus primarily
on the left side, which
is about building a
community around your API
and building a developer--
an API that your
developers love.
So there are actually
three types of APIs.
There's these services,
and you're probably
all familiar with this.
This is APIs that
are used in SOA.
Also in microservices,
these are APIs that
actually keep systems in sync.
And typically, we want to think
about onboarding and governance
when you have API as a service.
There are also APIs, more on
the left part of this triangle,
APIs as interactions, where
the purpose is actually
to bring these APIs out to
an app, or to a web app.
Specifically, for making
sure that people can interact
with your organization.
And there are
companies like Netflix,
for example, who are doing
this at a big scale, who
have specific APIs
for specific devices
and specific interactions
that they offer.
And the purpose is, of course,
to make it as performance
and as best as possible
for the user experience.
And this is where
techniques like GraphQL
come in, where the
device actually
asks which data it wants,
and the API actually
wants to combine several
APIs in one, just
to make it easy for a
device to get its data.
And then the last thing--
I think a sip of water.
The third thing is
the APIs as products.
And this is,
typically, where you
see that organization
who are not in technology
see something new.
Apart from offering
physical products,
your APIs, your
interactions, can also
be a product that you
offer to your customers
or to your partners,
for example.
And you could also think
about monetizing this,
asking money for these projects.
You are offering
something, so you
could think about a monetization
strategy on top of your APIs.
So that having said, these
APIs fit in ecosystems.
And if you think about the
Facebook API, the Google Maps
API, or the Twitter API, these
are all public ecosystems
that everybody knows.
But it turns out that
most APIs are actually
internal-- internal to
organizations, where they're
being used within the
organization for apps,
or maybe just for apps
that the company has
out there in the market.
And there's
something interesting
happening in the
middle layers, where
we used to have organizations
working together
with their partners as a
business-to-business model,
where they used to offer
technologies like Swift,
or FTPing files to each
other, or maybe sending tapes
to each other.
And we see that these
interactions are now
turning to become more and
more going over APIs as well.
So if you think about this,
most APIs are internal,
and the minority of
APIs are actually
these APIs that have these
beautiful developer portals.
Why should we care about what
a developer thinks of these?
So we sometimes
talk to customers,
and they say, well, we
are offering a service.
We are a big bank, or
we are a prime retailer.
And the developers, they
just have to use our API
and they have no choice.
And yeah, you could
be right with that.
But if you think about
it a little bit more,
there's a lot of friction
that you are actually
adding to every
interaction that you
are doing, if your API is not
an API that developers love.
And just that these developers,
they don't want to waste time.
It's not that they're lazy, but
they want to do things easy.
If they can use an SDK and
just have a few lines of code
to interact with your
company, then they're happy.
And if they're happy,
there's a chance
that they're using your APIs
more and more, with more great
ideas, and more interactions.
And that's what
it actually out--
that's what [INAUDIBLE].
We're not changing the business
model for our customers.
We're making sure that they
can do the thing they're doing.
If it's a retailer and
they're selling products,
it's just that we're selling
products through APIs.
So the more
interactions you have,
the better the
organization works.
And that's why it's
important that developers
care about your API.
So that's my introduction.
I just want to go over
a few things which
we've seen within organizations
that actually make a great API.
And it's just my
list of seven things.
And we'll just get
over them one by one.
And after that, I'll
move into a demo,
where I'm actually going to
show what's on the slide here.
So things like self-service,
like great documentation,
or a low-friction sign-up, they
are tremendously important.
And the most popular API
programs out there, they
do exactly this.
So first, these are screenshots
of customers of Apigee,
with their developer portal.
The thing with
these companies is
that they have a really
easy developer portal,
where it's quick to
discover what the APIs are,
what interactions developers can
have with these organizations.
And it's really easy
to go push a button
and get access immediately.
Maybe it's not full API, or
maybe it's just mock data,
or maybe there's just
a rate limit on it.
But it's easy to get access.
It's easy to go into
the developer portal
and to get started.
The other thing, which is
closely related to this,
is if you want to get
started, you need onboard.
You need to make yourself
known to the organization.
And if you have to
know the guy, if you
have to attend the meeting,
if they have to type you
into a database, and then
it takes three weeks,
then there's a lot of friction.
And people, or developers,
they will easily
turn from one API to
another if they can get
started quickly,
because developers,
they want to do things quickly.
So this is a screenshot
of the developer
portal of Ticketmaster.
Probably you're aware
of, they sell tickets.
But 10% of their
ticket sales is now
going through APIs, which they
are not selling themselves,
but they are sold through
third-party apps or web apps.
And I like to think that
this is just because it's
so easy to sign up.
It's so easy to find yourself
their APIs to get started with,
is that they are finding
a lot of developers.
There's not a whole
lot of fields on there
to be filled in.
There's no social security
number or anything
that you need to think about.
Of course, you need to accept
the terms of conditions, terms
and conditions, but
nobody reads them anyway.
You can just scroll through it.
I didn't say that.
And then this is
about documentation.
Developers, they like to
know how your API works.
So there should be a place
where you could actually
scroll through all the APIs,
have an overview of what they
do, and then get some more
details on which headers
you need to use,
which URLs to call,
which parameters I can provide,
and anything like that.
And there are great
tools out there
these days, like OpenAPI--
it used to be called Swagger--
which can help you automatically
generate, from an API design,
great and beautiful
documentation.
And that's what you want to
offer to your developers.
But it's not just
documentation, right?
You could have really
beautiful documentation,
but if your API
design sucks, it's
not going to be successful.
So developers actually
know what they don't like.
If you look on the slide,
it's like, get all docs,
and save doc, and that's
quite easy, still,
to understand what it does.
But if you think about
create recurring doc walk,
or replace sitting
docs with running docs,
it's getting to
start complicated.
Then that's actually
if you-- if you
follow such kind
of model, that's
actually where it turns out.
And developers, they have
to research for a long time.
They have to read all the
documentation to actually
understand what your API does.
So don't do this.
And do something like this.
So the developers
in the audience
have asked you about REST, and
if I tell you my API is REST,
you probably have a pretty
good idea how the API works.
You won't need a lot of
study, a lot of research,
to actually use my API.
It's just a bunch
of URLs, which are
entities, which includes get
to read from those entities
to get a list, or search.
And you could create entities.
You could update them.
You could delete them.
And it's quite easy
how everything works.
And if you're building
some weird own protocol
or something, it's not going
to make any developer happy.
So there are a bunch
of other things,
like the RPC GraphQ
on Hypermedia,
which are kind of new
things, new tools that you
can offer to your developers.
RPC is, and primarily
Google is investing in it
with gRPC, which is a protocol
that you could use when
performance is really
important and you
have a pretty good idea
how your API works,
and it's not going
to change a lot.
And things like GraphQL,
I mentioned it earlier,
where the device actually asks
for exactly what data it needs,
like a query.
And the API makes sure that
exactly that data is sent back.
So it saves the device
probably making a few calls
to get the data it needs.
And then there's Hypermedia,
which is actually an API.
In every response, there
is a URL, or multiple URLs.
So developers actually
read the response
and follow the URLs in there
to go from one API call
to another, and actually follow
the lead, follow the links.
So when you're using this, and
use it with sense, of course,
you could actually build an API
that's well-known by developers
because these are
well-known techniques,
but also really
fully functional.
The same thing with API
design holds for security.
If you stick to the things
that your developers know--
so if you're building your
own SDK, you compile it.
You give it to developers.
And you say to the
developers, well, this
is what you have to
use to use our API.
This SDK does the security.
But we're not going to
tell you what it does,
and we're not going to provide
you the sourcecode anywhere.
The developer is
basically in the dark.
And I'm wondering if they
even trust this, right?
So what you need
to do is use things
like OAuth, which has become
a kind of a de facto standard
for security when you need
to do user authentication.
This user can change his
user credentials for a token,
and then with the token, they
can do some actions on the API,
specifically for one
and only one user
from one and only one device.
But our APIs, for example, a get
location or get docs location,
I don't know, an API
that doesn't really
need user authentication,
for those APIs,
it might be fine just
to have an API key.
Right, it's not that
you need to use the most
security for all your APIs.
Make it easy where you can, and
just send a client ID or an API
key for an API where
that's sufficient.
And if you do all that,
without going any further,
I think you're
doing a great job.
And I think your APIs
will be really great,
and developers will be
enthusiastic about it.
But you could take it a little
further, and most popular APIs
from companies out there
like Google Cloud or Twitter,
they have these
SDKs, which just make
it a little bit
easier for developers
to start using your
APIs from their code.
Of course, you
have to offer SDKs
for the most popular
programming platforms,
like Go, Java, Node.js, Python.
And of course, not
only offer the API,
but also provide
sourcecode of the API.
So that's why you
see here there are
links to get them, for example.
And then there is
another thing, which
is a kind of a console,
a live testing.
And this is kind of
state of the art.
So most new developer
portals have
something like this,
where they make
it really easy for a
developer to try out the API.
And I will show this in my
demo, where I'm actually
going to go into the portal
and see, discover an API that I
like, and just make a few
calls to see how the API works,
to see what responses I get
back, what parameters I can
send in, without actually
needing to register,
without actually needing
to install the SDK
or something like that.
It's really easy.
And you're probably familiar
with a Hello World program.
This makes it really
easy for a developer
to build a Hello World.
And we call this sometimes,
time to first Hello World.
It could be just under
a minute with this.
So that's it.
It's my list of seven things.
I just want to move on to
how you can do this yourself.
So I'm going to
switch to my laptop
to see if it can open up Apigee
Edge, where I'm going to show
a few developer portals.
And if there's time,
which I think there is,
I'm also going to show you
the technical part, what
you can actually do to expose an
API from your backend systems.
Great.
Yeah.
This is the developer
portal of TomTom,
and they are a
customer of Apigee.
They are actually a
competitor of Google Maps,
so I was thinking,
should I show them here?
But I like their
developer portal
so much that I think they
deserve some attention as well.
You probably know TomTom.
They sell these
navigation devices
that you could put on the
windscreen of your car
to find your way from A to
B. But nobody is actually
using them anymore, right?
You have your navigation
on your phone,
or you have it
built into your car.
So TomTom has to change
their business model a lot.
And they actually found out
that the data they have,
which is maps and
routing services
and all that, that's still
really, really valuable.
So that's actually what
they're focusing on.
And for them, APIs are
a [INAUDIBLE] product.
And on their developer
portal, as a developer,
I can actually go
there and discover
what I can do with their API.
So just to take a quick peek,
we can do something with maps,
online routing,
searching online traffic.
They are moving into sports
equipment, which has an API.
And they're still the bridge.
So if I go on and I'm
trying to discover
what I can do with this API, I
just get a lot of information
on how the routing API works.
Routing can be done with
single routing requests,
with a batch, or a
kind of a matrix.
And if I just follow on, go
to specific documentation,
I actually end up getting
the technical information
that I, as a developer,
actually am looking for.
How does the API look like?
What can I do with the API?
Which are the parameters?
How does a specific
request look like?
And how can I get started?
So if I then scroll
down a little bit,
we see there's an example URL.
So let me copy it
and give it a try.
And we see that there
is one field missing,
which is the API key.
Can see it, right?
Might be small.
There's a long URL with,
at the end, API key,
which still needs
to be inserted.
The API key is
actually something
that I, as a developer,
need to provide
to use the API of TomTom.
So I need to register.
I need to get an API key.
And let's see how easy that is.
So if I go back to the
TomTom developer portal,
there is this
button, Get Your Key.
And it actually requires
me to sign up or sign in.
And I actually have
an account already.
So I'm signing in.
And when I've done that,
I get to my list of apps.
So I actually tested
this out yesterday.
That's why there's
already a mapping app.
Let's create a new mapping app.
And there's something
like a callback URL.
That has to do with the OAuth
that I explained for security,
where you're being
redirected back to the app
after the user logs in.
It's not mandatory, so I'll
leave it empty for now.
And then the third
thing I need to provide
is something we
already talked about.
These are APIs as products.
So for TomTom, their
APIs are actually
grouped into these bundles.
I can use the mapping APIs,
I can use the routing APIs,
and online search APIs.
So for me, I'm
interested in maps.
And let's do it.
Terms and conditions.
Let's take our time to read
it and then create the app.
And there's my mapping API.
It's already there, and
it's already approved.
So this is the
purpose of TomTom.
They want to make
it as frictionless
as possible, as easy
as possible for me
as a developer to
start using the API.
So there's no approval
workflow, or somebody
who needs to click the button.
And there is my API key.
TomTom is actually
using this API key
to keep track of what I'm doing.
And at a certain
point, when they
think I'm doing too
many calls, they
might contact me about
getting a subscription,
or they might block me.
I don't know.
But this-- developer inactive.
That's great.
They deactivated me.
Or the key is not active yet.
Let's leave it with that.
The essence is that it's--
sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KEVIN BOUWMEESTER:
I can't hear you.
But it's fine.
It's OK.
The reality is that this
should be easy to get your key
and to get started with the API.
So something that
PayEasy has done
is to make it a little
bit easier for developers
to start using the API.
If I go to their developer
portal, and PayEasy,
some organization that is making
payments possible through APIs,
they've made a lot
of different APIs
around making
different payments.
So for example,
there is Android Pay.
And on their developer portal,
when I'm searching or browsing
through the APIs,
I actually have
this console that I had on my--
was from one of my last slides.
So this console is actually
quite extensive for PayEasy.
You can imagine that making a
payment, making an Android Pay
payment, is actually something
that needs to be really secure.
So there's a lot of security
mechanisms involved there.
There's a hash on there.
There's an OAuth token.
There's a client ID.
And all the things that I
need to provide are on here.
So if I click the headers,
there you see, there's a token,
there's an API key,
there's an HMAC hash that's
required to make an API call.
But luckily for me,
it's all pre-filled.
So all I need to do is
just to read through it,
to understand what they're
doing, and then make a call.
And in this call,
we're actually sending
a payload, where we're
making an Android Pay
payment with $1,222.
Then, if I go down,
as you can see,
the request, and I can
see the response that's
actually being transferred.
So for me as a developer,
this is what I like.
And I hope this is
something that you
get enthusiastic about as well.
And this is something that
organizations actually
are trying to achieve,
right, to offer
their APIs, their services,
but then it's easy--
easy to discover and
easy to get access.
So another thing
I want to show you
is the technical part of the
digital value chain, which
is more the right part,
where we're actually
trying to get services
and data we have
and to make it available
as an API that's secure,
an API that's clearly designed,
an API that gives me back
the right data, for example.
So this is Apigee Edge.
I'm now logged in more to the
UI where the API team works.
So in this UI, I
can manage my APIs,
and they are called API proxies,
because they are actually
an API proxy that--
proxy for something
in the backend.
So my API that I want to show
you is called The Caravan
Tracker, and for those
of you who are not Dutch,
you probably know,
understand, that the Dutch,
they go on holiday during the
summer with their caravans.
And the biggest problem for
the Dutch guys in the audience
is to figure out how
heavy their caravan can
be behind their car, right?
They know their car.
The big question is, how
heavy can my caravan be?
What's the maximum
weight I can tow?
So this API is actually
helping with that.
And it's just an example.
But in this example,
I'd like to show
what Apigee is adding
from functionality on
to make this API.
So this is the overview
page of my API.
And the thing that's
really important
is how I can call it, the
URL, and the backend, which
is the backend that lives
somewhere in the organization.
In this case, it's a backend
from the RDW, the [INAUDIBLE],,
the government agency
that keeps track
of all the cars on the
roads in the Netherlands.
They've published
a data set that I
can query with a license plate,
with a Dutch license plate.
So that's what I've done.
I want to quickly
open up my trace.
And on here, I can
visualize all the API
calls that are being executed.
All the API calls that
come in will be visualized.
And I can quickly explain you
what Apigee is doing in there.
So what I'm going to do,
I'm going to open my app--
hopefully I can visualize
it on the screen--
make a few calls, and then
explain what's happening.
So let me get it both on one
screen, if that's possible.
No, it's not.
Ah, it is.
So the trace is running
in the background,
and I have my app here.
I pre-filled the
license plate of my car,
and I pre-filled the weight
of a certain caravan.
Let's say, let's assume
my caravan is 2,000 kilos.
So I make a call, and we get
back information about my car,
about the weight of my car,
the weight of the caravan I
had requested, and
the maximum advised.
So my Porsche 911--
it's not really my car.
But it cannot tow anything.
It's typical for these sports
car, so they're useless.
They are useless
to go on holiday.
So that's why the
caravan is too heavy.
But really, it's
not about the app.
It's just a funny example
to make an API call.
In the background, you
actually see the API.
And you see that there is some
icons popping up and all that,
which I will explain.
I will just make another call,
and quickly make another call.
And there's a spike.
Yes.
So there were three calls.
Third one will hopefully pop up.
There it is.
And we see a kind of a flow
from the app to the backend,
and then the response from
the backend back to the app.
So that's actually what an
API proxy is doing in Apigee.
It's kind of in the middle.
And it can do a lot of
things being in the middle.
It can add security.
So we see the little
padlock in the icon,
and we call these
icons "policies."
That is adding an
API key verification.
So it requires
the app to provide
an API key, one of
the security things I
had on my slides, right?
We're also protecting against
too much traffic, which
means that somebody is
maybe misusing the API,
or maybe somebody is
really too enthusiastic
and he wants to test
all the cars he sees.
But typically, the spike
arrest policy will block this.
And they will prevent
too much traffic.
And too much traffic is not
really a problem for Apigee,
but it sometimes
is for the backend.
So that's why we
want to stop it.
So other things we are doing
is, for example, caching.
So we see my second call,
it was a lot quicker,
from 421 milliseconds to 53.
So that's great.
53 milliseconds for an API call.
And that's because we don't
need to get to the RDW
to get the data about this car.
We already know it.
We have cached this.
So providing a good caching
strategy, of course,
is something that you
want to put in your API.
Other things I'm
doing, I won't go
into a lot of technical details,
but the backend actually
returns all the data
I know about this car.
So they will have the price, the
catalog price of this Porsche.
They'll have the weight of
this Porsche, of course.
That's what I need.
They have the color
of the Porsche.
That's something I don't need.
So I actually can filter
out exactly what's
required for my API and
send back the right data
to be shown and
be used in my app.
So this is just a quick
example on what Apigee can do.
On the technical part of
the digital value chain,
making your APIs available
with the right security,
the right data, and the
right technical formats.
So just to conclude,
what you have seen
is how you could build your API.
You've seen loads of examples
of developer portals, of APIs.
How this should look like,
what you should not do,
and what you should do.
And I hope you
found it interesting
and you have a lot of fun
using or exposing your APIs.
We will here, waiting for
you, if you have questions
or you want to talk with
us about ABN AMRO case,
or about Apigee.
And we like to see you
here, if that's the case.
Thank you for coming,
and have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]